man kann sich mittlerweile gar nicht
mehr vorstellen dass es immer noch eine
steigerung gibt und dann kommt sie aber
doch gas und strom es wird nur immer
noch teurer die nebenkostenabrechnungen
explodieren und hier sehen sie die
gasrechnung des grauens über diese
abschlagszahlung spricht aktuell ganz
deutschland statt bis jetzt 721 euro
eine erhöhung auf
2588 euro und das pro monat eine
erhöhung also von über 250 prozent
und dieser horror rechnungen gehört
diesen becker tobias plaz sein name
bäckermeister und er weiß nicht mehr wie
er mit diesen enormen summen umgehen
soll ja die versprochenen entlastungen
viel zu gering wie wenig bei der hart
arbeitenden mittelschicht ankommt wird
in diesem vergleich hier ganz gut
deutlich ein arbeitender single kriegt
267 euro mehr im nächsten jahr bei einem
bürgergeld bezieher also ehemals hartz4
sind es hingegen
752 euro und wie sieht's bei rentnern
und studierenden aus der rentner bekommt
bei einer jahresrente von 12.000 eur 855
euro mehr der student
755 noch ungleicher wird der vergleich
zwischen einem arbeiten in single und
einer familie mit zwei kindern während
der single mit einem jahreseinkommen von
28.800 euro lediglich 267 euro mehr
bekommt sind es bei einer familie mit
zwei kindern bei einem jahreseinkommen
von 31 1200 euro ganze
1582 euro sollen was tobias plaz jetzt
vorhat und wie er seine bäckerei retten
kann sprechen wir mit ihm direkt herr
platz ich grüße sie was ging ihnen durch
den kopf als er den brief erhalten
aufgemacht und dann diese
schocknachricht gesehen haben ja schon
guten morgen war die zeichen standen ja
schon so dass es teurer wird aber als
dann die blanken zahlen vor einem lagen
da war natürlich schon im ersten moment
etwas etwas technik die man das dann
alles umsetzen kann man muss dazu sagen
das ist jetzt noch mal die
das gas was wir für die hausheizung und
die warmwasserbereitung und so weiter
benötigen der backofen da habe ich gott
sei dank noch einen vertrag bis zum jahr
sind ja man kann davon ausgehen dass das
dann nach und bis in einem kleinbetrieb
wir haben also hinten die backstube von
den laden also kein
großer kette oder ähnliches und für uns
sind es rund 45.000 euro mehr fürs gas
natürlich eine riesensumme
gehen sie jetzt frage was ist ihr plan
um das stemmen zu können diese hohe
summe
ja im prinzip haben wir eigentlich nur
die möglichkeit die preise an unsere
kunden weiterzugeben also wir haben
keine großen reserven im vergangenen
jahr haben wir den laden neu gebaut also
die
reserven sind nicht mehr in dem maße
vorhanden als jahren kann wieder wir
stemmen das irgendwie aus anderen
taschen und dann muss man halt eben auch
die verbraucher hoffen dass die einen
weiterhin
unterstützen wir versuchen den
verbrauchern oder unseren kunden immer
alles zu bieten und hoffen jetzt
natürlich darauf dass sie auch bei uns
weiterhin ihre brötchen kaufen aber die
bewirtung die ich habe jetzt schon dass
der eine oder andere dann eben zum
billigen konkurrenz abwandern also
speziell die discounter die natürlich
viel weniger für ihre backwaren
verlangen sind sie sind sie wütend auf
die politik dass ich das alles jetzt
gerade so entwickelt hat
auf jeden fall also was mich an der
politik stört ist einfach dass die ja
die kleinen mal wieder total vergessen
haben also da bleibt immer bei den ich
sag mal im lokalen unterwegs immer groß
getönt ja wie wichtig ihnen dann das
handwerk ist und so weiter und wenn es
dann darum geht jemand zu entlasten oder
jemand was zuzuschustern dann sind
irgendwie die großbetriebe und das muss
man auch einfach sehen wir die
handwerksbäcker die schauen in die röhre
und die bankindustrie die kommt dann
eben in das energie größten dämpfungs
programm und lacht sich da natürlich ins
fäustchen und das ist einfach eine
ungerechtigkeit die ich absolut nicht
nachvollziehen kann also ich weiß nicht
welcher partei von den ampel-koalition
ihren das
soeben im kopf drin ist dass man hier
für die kleinen nichts tun musst ist
schon irgendwie gruppen und dass das
macht natürlich wütend
mit einem bürgergeld bezieher gesprochen
was sagen sie zu aussagen wie diesen
hier
wenn man jetzt zum beispiel den
mindestlohn zugrunde liegt und geht
arbeiten muss man ja teilweise seien
becker auf 56 uhr stellen und ich als
hartz4
schlafe aus und bekomme mit miete und
unterstützung der grundsicherung
850 900 euro wenn ich jetzt arbeiten
gehen würde mit diesem gestellten wecker
komme ich vielleicht auf 200 250 euro
mehr die relation ist zu gering deswegen
sprach ich damals schon mal an dass
entweder hartz4 zu hoch ist und einen
mindestlohn zu gering aber dieser sprung
von
arbeitslos 24 stunden freizeit und neun
stunden arbeiten das ist zu wenig dieses
diese differenz ist zu wenig also es
wenn weiter sagte ganz klar arbeiten
lohnt sehe ich nicht was sagen sie dazu
was entgegnen sie
ja also die ungerechtigkeit bei uns
jetzt im ich sage mal im süden von
deutschland bei uns im betrieb
beispielsweise da hat die 112 euro
verdient muss man auch ganz klar sehen
die das lohngefüge ist natürlich in
anderen bundesländern noch ein bisschen
anders wir jetzt hier im süden aber
trotzdem
ja das macht einen natürlich noch mehr
wütend weil man versucht jeden tag seine
mitarbeiter zu motivieren dass er eine
gute arbeit abgeben und wenn dann solche
aussagen kommen das ja das trifft
einheit einem in der magengegend und man
sagt das kann ja wohl nicht sein dass
man in einem staat leben muss ich arbeit
nicht mehr lohnt und die wird ja auch
vor allem ja sagt sie
neben vielen dank dass sie sich heute
vormittag die zeit genommen habe alles
gute
[Musik]